[Musique]
cameron todd willingham vous êtes
coupable de meurtre au premier degré sur
ordre de l'état du texas je vous
condamne à la peine de mort
c' est la première personne qui m'ont en
visite depuis un bail ça fait combien de
temps en tout huit ans en prison tu
compte les jours dans le couloir le
temps n'existe pas il s'est arrêté dès
que la condamnation est tombée alors si
vous me disiez ce qui s'est passé
walker un homme qui peut pas sauver ses
enfants
le mérite pas de vie je vous jure que
j'ai pas tué mes enfants élisabeth en
jeu tenait plus qu'à un petit profit
j'ai découvert un homme vulnérable avec
beaucoup de sensibilité
pour moi l'état du texas à m
vous n'avez pas interroger les témoins
qui ont rogné ce qu'ils avaient déclaré
il avait mobile ils avaient les moyens
ce monstre a brûlé ses filles et doit
mourir son avocat a décidé que todt
était coupable depuis le début il n'a
pas trouvé de scientifiques qui
contredisent leur expert le reconnaît
que son procès a été un massacre et
laissez pas vos émotions vous guider mes
émotions parce que c'est une femme c'est
ça super je vais terminer votre boulot
[Musique]
vous avez lu de découvrir un sens à sa
vie
ça dit que vivre c'est souffrir et pour
survivre il faut trouver un sens à la
souffrance j'ai envie de vivre
c'est pour ça qu'on ira jusqu'au bout à
votre avis pourquoi todt s'est confié à
vous j'ai pas le droit de parler de ce
genre de chose qui vous a dit pas en
parler le procureur jacques salsa
suivent ont exécuté un homme qui a rien
fait jules nahb pour le mois de juin
les soi disant experts qui l'ont appelée
ont peut-être eu beaucoup d'incendiés
ça prouve que tu dis pour rien ça fera
aucune différence
je suis pas là pour être sauvé je suis
là pour mourir
est-ce qu'on a une chance que ça
aboutisse vous croyez que ça concerne
uniquement todd tel système qu'est fois
ça marche pas il me reste dix jours à
vivre
et si je me remet à espérer les dix
jours vont passer comme ça
[Musique]
oui je sais mais moi j'espère